we are here to build tact to support the
civilian population for that end you
must avoid killing it at all cost we
can't help them and kill them at the
same time it just a humanly possible now
this Wars been running eight years now
given your reputation and your from
middle bran our hope is that you're the
man who will give the job down
most of us here will know general
McMaster man who kicked out hider in the
sack your wall talkative troops in order
move the needle a little bit show
everyone a nice looking set of graphs
just finish this thing it's a lost cause
can't stay in Afghanistan forever that's
what I'm gonna win it my team and I are
about to embark on a new direction what
is this music we build Afghanistan into
a free and prosperous nation or smile
for the cameras look
sounds a lot like the old direction I
come here manage this war and I sure as
[ __ ] didn't come here close it out
it's my job to ensure that your personal
ambitions are kept in check seems to me
that we are here with our guns trying to
convince these people were really nice
guys an easy weapon I'm gonna crack this
[Music]
you're not here to win you're here to
clean up the mess
for the times they are a-changin
[Music]
stana you have spoken to the president
once in 70 days that general you must
know is a war you will never win may I
help you No